vote flat time how long this shell stays
in the air where do I go where am I
gonna take it
which equation so here this one right
this is time and alpha just on their own
all right so you can see you've got so
many equations to choose from
you've got to think carefully about what
you want and what we know okay so I'm
gonna say when I have this first result
45 okay I'm gonna get one answer and
they're not do the other one
intersection T is going to be 10 on cos
45 close 45 is jacked angle one on route
2 right so therefore it comes onto the
top of fashion so I just get Tambor in
two seconds okay so this one answer when
I take my other one now 71 degrees okay
I could punch this into a calculator
right and get a value but I think I can
do a bit better than that right because
where did this Sony would come from it
came from three right so what I can do
is draw for myself a triangle and I can
put in well there's my alpha if tan
alpha is three which side is going to be
three opposite and adjacent right so
opposite over adjacent town of this hour
[ __ ] is you three right so if I want to
work out what cause of this new alpha is
I'm going to need the hypotenuse which
is root n okay so now instead of
chucking this into you know the tacho
again you're missing on I can say it's
tan on cos alpha which is 110 110 you
see it so 10 root 10 seconds okay now
let's just compare these for a second
you always want to get it what these
numbers mean
this second approach takes root 5 times
longer than this approach
whatever five is two points off me right
does that make sense it does right
because obviously it has a much greater
distance to travel
okay so that's why it takes so much
longer even though it arrives at
sensible okay now I'm rapidly running
out of room impact angle and velocity
impact angle and velocity how am I gonna
do these just be careful by the way of
what you call your angles which equation
will I go to how can I get theater of it
because what I know what I've got in the
moment is equations for X dot and y dot
yes so how do I get feed only so I'm
gonna usually we are we resolve the
velocity right what we did at the start
was we took an angle and a velocity and
then we broke it up into X's and Y's
okay so now I'm gonna go back to that
I've got to reverse the process okay so
the piece information that I'm going to
need totally running out of space on
each other's um the X dot and the V dot
at the moment of impact that make sense
next time V dot at the moment impact sir
right sorry I should just say impact
we'll take one case at a time I know
we've got to let's just do the first one
because if it's in plot I know three
things about the moment of impact
okay or where the impact is I know where
it takes place right and I also know
when it takes place right namely that
time - okay so which equations are am I
gonna throw this into is right and
here's what
okay so I can say okay now I'm gonna get
to that in about ten seconds
when you say stops is your time okay
because we want to know X start and why
not and then we can get these two ok you
ran into a problem because for instance
in X dot there's no interpreter time
right and why not there is a place to
put time but you don't know what any of
the other two are so you kind of stuck
so I'm going to need to know more
information I'm gonna have to go for
these equations right that's gonna bring
in these other piece of information here
okay so for instance let's have a go at
our X shall we I know where it impacts
daily mm okay that should equal to 200
times my time right cos alpha that make
sense so what happens this is two
sorry I'm one step ahead of myself hmm
does that make sense
what other options if I go where else
can I go I'm never this this equation
here right what's it gonna tell me Y is
equal to sorry that's I know what that
is that's a thousand right equals minus
5t squared there's T right
so that's root 200 right so T squared
should be just 200 plus 210 root sign
yeah okay what am I got here that's a
thousand plus can you see what's
happening you see it mm over there I'm
gonna get the same result right which is
pleasant because that's gonna give us
the same angle what do I do with that
okay I'm gonna stop stop I want you
think about it you had a whole a double
on predator on commission have a little
equation there I've deliberately
resisted rocket all this stuff off
because you need it okay you know where
you gonna put it right Chuck white into
velocity okay which equation would I put
into okay X star equals to 200
which is so this is 300 times 100 to 100
on route
sorry 200 on routine that's a hundred
tree right okay happy about hmm this X
star right okay so I should probably
take it to Y but as well right
I know what time is you know an alpha is
okay let's let's finish this off all
right got minus 10 times this team right
plus 200 sine 45 okay so what are we get
here minus 100 root 2 plus 300 on route
2 yeah be that that's 100 root 2 isn't
it once you rationalize so that's 0 what
does this mean
okay let's step back please don't pay
attention actually deathly sort of
Pantene okay this alpha right you didn't
need to work yeah it came from here
that's what was subbing it that's why we
get the same result
okay we want this angle right which you
can get from these two okay remember we
talked about gurus all being backwards
so what does this actually mean okay
think about it this is how fast it's
moving that way horizontally okay so
that's gonna be my horizontal velocity
what's this mean why that's equal to
zero that's the vertical velocity right
if the vertical velocity is zero isn't
it doing this cuz melech velocity is by
getting it upwards and got any downwards
tinea right on okay so it's a horizontal
angle okay so that's gonna continue this
on Monday but